una serie que ha atraído a espectadores
de todo el mundo
la historia de una joven estadounidense
que inicia una nueva vida en la capital
francesa
un selfie frente al sacrificó un paseo
romántico por el guaial un Brindis con
champán frente a la torre Eiffel y una
escena al aire libre son las escenas de
París que los turistas buscan Incluso se
pueden encontrar visitas guiadas Emily
en París
solo tiene que cruzar la plaza de su
apartamento y llega a la panadería
es la serie en este edificio del quinto
distrito de la ciudad ahora es un lugar
donde los turistas se detienen para una
foto luego pueden probar un guasón en la
panadería favorita de Emily Emily
Encarna realmente París y la cultura
francesa pero la verdadera Emily
Parisina podría parecerse más a esta
parodia bicicletas alquiladas que no
funcionan y quedarse atrapada en el
metro por una huelga de trabajadores una
versión más cercana a como los parecidos
ven su día a día
personas viviendo en la calle la ciudad
es bonita y limpia la gente es muy
amable eso existe en la vida real pero
no es solo eso
es un ideal de París ordenado y limpio
algo sacado de una revista
la serie y el París que retrata son
fuente de frustración para algunos en el
ayuntamiento
el París del programa es estupendo para
soñar despiertos desde el sofá Pero es
un París que deberíamos cambiar en
términos de movilidad y transformación
de edificios en términos de Cómo podemos
ayudar a la gente a cambiar la ciudad y
hacerla más ecológica
Mientras tanto el París de Emily sigue
siendo un París imaginado por Hollywood